so if the filmmakers that reach out to
you and they ask for advice on certain
things is that one of the things that
you recommend to slow down a little bit
you know I think this era is one full of
contradictions and the you know what is
that
Einstein line or someone like the sign
of intelligence is to be able to handle
two conflicting ideas we're asked to do
that all the time in filmmaking now so I
think the logical approach for artists
working today is on one hand to be
incredibly prolific ubiquitous and thus
radically collaborative how do you have
a generative life today
when sustainability is such a question
right yet because the barriers to entry
the cost of creation and distribution
really have low been loaded so much we
have this other necessity just because
we can make something doesn't mean that
we should just because we can say
something doesn't mean that we should
that you want your ideas to be able to
percolate to become something that is
not just the collective unconscious you
know that that we're all thinking about
these things you know we all get the
same inputs but how do you get your
unique perspective on that in time it's
certainly the best way to do that but
you have to say to yourself all right I
need to build my audience I need to
connect with a community I need to move
this all forward go go go
with that same sort of piece of like I
need it to really stand out there's so
much this is now the time of abundance
it means with the bar has been lifted
for everybody we have to reach that much
higher and how are we going to do that
when we're also being asked to be
eat profoundly generative when you look
at a film made nowadays can you see the
ones that did take their time with
certain things versus the ones that rush
where it's go go go
money's on the line and we can only get
this person at this price for this long
it's hard it's hard to say that because
I think that the question of inspiration
where does inspiration comes from you
know sometimes it comes from you just
being right in the center of it you know
necessity is the mother and invention
and inspiration other times I think it
is that that somebody has taken in a lot
contemplated and really thought how to
be additive to that I'm not sure that
you can say like oh this is the the
great work they clearly had the time and
this is the thing that just burst forth
and it's not as great or maybe it's
greater like it's hard to see sometimes
energy you know is pre-programmed and
sometimes it's just explosive
you